not answer general questions on YouTube
answer specific questions my view count
looks good my channel looks good my
photos on Instagram look good that's
just appearance what's the substance
underneath the surface we're going to be
looking at four YouTube success secrets
that will help you gain an unfair
advantage on YouTube right now there's a
lot of people on YouTube that are saying
and preaching things that they're not
living there's a lot of people who are
teaching things that maybe they got
lucky on one time or they haven't fully
tested or verified
the truth is competition is rising on
YouTube so it's important that we find
ways to create an unfair Advantage so
that we can get discovered and get ahead
we've been going through a series on the
think media podcast called the
Battleground for views where we have
been discovering some classic military
strategies that can be applied to Modern
challenges on YouTube today on the
classic book on war covering military
strategies from General Carl Von
klausowitz we're going to be looking at
four YouTube success secrets that will
help you gain an unfair advantage on
YouTube right now number one strike fast
when you see the opportunity here's the
quote the backbone of surprise is fusing
speed with secrecy the truth is on
YouTube speed matters especially if
you're just starting let me tell you a
story back in 2015 when I was working
full-time at a church at a full-time
nine-to-five job I was even working on
weekends as I had Sunday service duties
and really I had about a day and a half
off each week I had to be incredibly
strategic with my time as I was trying
to grow my YouTube channels I actually
was working on a channel called video
influencers at the time and this channel
maybe had a few hundred subscribers
perhaps around a thousand when I saw an
opportunity the promise of the channel
was interviews with entrepreneurs
business owners and content creators
that were building their influence with
video and it was also tips and tricks
around how to get more views and it was
covering not just YouTube but video
platforms overall and I remember my work
week was really Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday and then I had Friday
off I had most of Saturday off and then
Saturday night we would oftentimes need
to set up the sanctuary at church and
get ready for Sunday morning so number
one I either had to create content after
hours or I had to create content on my
day off but I'll never forget I was
studying Twitter and Google news and
looking for different things that were
happening in the online video space on
Friday morning the beginning of my day
off I was sipping some coffee when I saw
an opportunity at this time there was a
brand new live streaming app that was
gaining popularity it was called meerkat
and everyone was blown away that you
could just live stream from your phone
you could bring on a guest people like
Gary vaynerchuk were talking about it
but what happened on this Friday was
that was the day that Periscope was
announced a major competitor that was
expected to disrupt meerkat so I'm
sitting at our apartment in Irvine
California sipping my coffee reading the
news when I get an idea I think about
man this is going to be a video that
people want to see that people are
searching for essentially meerkat versus
Periscope now I had already been testing
out the app meerkat I knew some things
about it so for the following hours of
that day though I began to test out
Periscope compare the two apps study
online research everything I could about
them and prepare a video outline for a
video that I ultimately created the next
morning so it's a Saturday in 2015 and I
wake up on Saturday morning and all of
the testing and the prep operation I had
done on Friday was now ready to be
Consolidated into a video essentially
titled meerkat versus Periscope and I
remember and sure enough because I
looked ahead and thought about not just
the strategy but the speed of the
strategy I shot the video edited the
video and then released it on that same
Saturday now at this time I want to say
our videos were maybe getting a few
hundred views and if we got a thousand
views that was absolutely incredible and
this video quickly Rose to 10 000 I
think maybe 15 or 20 000 views which is
what we would call vfm viral for me it
led to thousands of new subscribers it
was actually one of our first breakout
videos on that channel video influencers
what's the lesson speed matters the
backbone of surprise is fusing speed
with secrecy number two choose winnable
battles here's the quote where absolute
superiority is not attainable you must
produce a relative one at the decisive
Point by making skillful use of what you
have so what does he say saying here the
general is saying that you got to be
self-aware of whether you can win the
battle or not is it too is that
particular video topic too crowded is
that angle on the topic too crowded do
you not have an opportunity to attain
absolute superiority and that particular
YouTube initiative if not focus all of
your forces on one decisive point and
make skillful use of what you do have
friend I know it can be discouraging
when you think about the competition but
you want to analyze is what advantages
do you have could it be that you can
move faster than others could it be that
you have time that other people don't
have that you could focus on a very
small Niche but you could have absolute
superiority in that Niche and I don't
mean like your whole channel topic I
mean that you could be the first to talk
about meerkat versus Periscope because
maybe no one else is moving that fast or
not too many people care but enough care
when you're starting a new channel and
trying to break out around one topic but
here's another quote from General Klaus
surprise becomes effective when we
suddenly face the enemy at one point
with far more troops than he expected
this type of numerical superiority is
quite distinct from the numerical
superiority in general it is the most
powerful medium in The Art of War and I
love this quote from the general because
he actually hits this theme over and
over that you should take all of your
troops and concentrate them at One
Singular Point again this is one of the
reasons why we teach asq answer specific
questions not answer general questions
on YouTube answer specific questions can
you make a video about something very
specific something that hits one
specific point and you want to overwhelm
the algorithm overwhelm the competition
with maybe far more troops than expected
what would that mean maybe it's far more
research far more energy into the video
far more editing into to the video one
of the things we teach inside of our
program video ranking Academy is the
skyscraper method for video it actually
was an old blogging technique that can
be applied to video where you just make
a better video like you think about what
are the videos that exist around a
particular topic maybe they're outdated
maybe they're a few years old can you
concentrate your efforts your energy
your research your time into one
particular point to break through
remember how do we stand out amongst
competition we can't divide our forces
dilute our energy be distracted we're
trying to think about can we concentrate
our energy to break through at one point
and just like I broke out with the
meerkat versus Periscope video
eventually you do get noticed you have
subscribers some people are paying
attention so you can afford to be a
little less strategic but when you're
just starting trying to get your first a
thousand or ten thousand or even a
hundred thousand subscribers you gotta
choose winnable battles and I think this
powerful point from the general will be
helpful an example of this is the power
of niching down like let's say you had
an entertainment Channel and it would be
the difference of having an
entertainment Channel trying to cover
every single show on every single
streaming platform for any one
individual that's too much content to do
a great job at but alternatively what if
you went really deep with one show a
show that I've personally enjoyed is
called succession it just ended it was
Four Seasons it's on Max so it's a
little bit sketchy but one of the
reasons why I love it is because it is
about succession and literally Logan Roy
built a media company he's got four kids
and now that I have two kids I'm trying
to learn from the show like what not to
do like this is definitely not the
culture of the company and or the family
that I would want to create and so at
least those parallels you know are
interesting to me but what's been
fascinating is I've probably watched two
three four hours of YouTube content
about the show not just show Recaps or
ending explain but literally
psychologists breaking down the
characters different like psychoanalysts
talking about narcissism and how that
shows up in the characters and the
different types here's the point there's
individuals that are going incredibly
deep with this one show they're taking
it to places that might surprise you
they are concentrating their troops
their energy at that one decisive Point
another example of this would be like a
tech channel that focuses on tools for
creators versus all consumer Tech if you
catch the hint that's actually think
media strategy as I started to think
about okay what's a decisive point that
we could maybe create a little bit of an
edge in it would be okay if we cover all
of Tech I would go to CES in Las Vegas
and realize that is a big nut to crack
lots of TVs smartphones smart robot
vacuum cleaners Tech is pretty massive
so how could we Niche that down could we
talk about even just all kinds of PCS
and graphic cards and all that kind of
stuff well even that is so massive and a
little bit not my deepest expertise
let's Niche down more what about tools
for creators this channel the guard
rails here and this is actually our
other channel think media is like is it
a tool Creator would use to create
content so sure maybe how to build a
video at any PC or something about a
laptop maybe headphones but how many
headphone videos do you need early on on
think media I got a little bit
distracted started getting into audio
file headphones kind of not relevant for
tools for creators mostly cameras
microphones lighting the punch line is
taking whatever energy whatever troops
you have and when you're facing the
enemy you want to go at one point with
far more troops than expected what is
that compounding and stacking up those
videos how many uploads can I do around
a particular show a particular Niche a
particular brand a particular subject
matter can I begin to build my brand and
my authority around one thing number two
choose winnable battles this video was
brought to you by stream yards stream
yard is our go-to platform for streaming
to YouTube and Facebook with an
incredibly easy to use interface for
built-in branding transitions text lower
thirds and seamlessly bringing on guests
it really is one of the best options
when it comes to live streaming and
what's so cool is they've implemented a
brand new feature called local recording
take control of your audio and video
with local recordings by separating out
your audio and video from your guests
this feature gives you the control over
your content for later use making it
perfect for podcasts and video creators
just go to streamwoodthink.com to get
started now number three lead by example
this quote is actually coming from a
different General and that's General
George Patton he says this do everything
you ask of those you command General
George Patton was known to lead his
soldiers by example why he's best known
for commanding troops during World War
II and perfecting the art of tank
warfare his troops knew he was more than
willing to personally get into the fight
during World War One For example he was
shot in the leg while directing tanks
after he repeatedly exposed himself to
enemy fire question for you are you
telling your audience and viewers to do
things you don't really do are you
asking your team to do things you don't
really do you know people want to follow
bold courageous action-taking leaders
who have sacrificed and have earned
respect the quote is do everything you
ask of those you command and here's why
I think this is such a powerful strategy
is because it's hard there's a lot of
people on YouTube that are saying and
preaching things that they're not living
there's a lot of people who are teaching
things that maybe they got lucky on one
time or they haven't fully tested or
verified and a lot of creators who are
all words but not a lot of action and so
if we do the hard work of being
courageous of going out into the field
into the line of fire of getting dirt
under our fingernails one of the things
that I was passionate about when it came
to video is I wanted real video
experience I didn't want to just start a
Channel about video because it was a
chance to make money I saw the financial
opportunity I understand stood affiliate
marketing but I wanted to over
credentialize myself by jumping on
planes filming weddings using cameras at
different events filming interviews
testing gear having experience making
mistakes getting scars going through the
pain going through the different editing
having to transcode many different video
formats early on because my computer
couldn't handle them AVCHD using this
codec so it would edit smooth and
Premiere color grading exporting lenses
mistakes all this different stuff and
it's that time it's the Blood Sweat and
Tears behind the content that has been
helpful I think to think media's success
I don't want to ask you as a listener of
the think media podcast to do something
that I am not willing nor have not done
myself I don't want to ask somebody on
think media to try a strategy that
hasn't been tested do everything you ask
of those that you command lead by
example and I know that this point is
heavy and you might be earlier on in
your career saying Sean I actually don't
have a ton of experience yet I actually
haven't really put in a ton of time yet
or maybe you're shifting into a new
domain a new discipline a new area of
learning but I want to encourage you to
be honest about where you are now and
lead by example where you are now but
also commit to the continuous process of
becoming a leader worth following it's
shocking how many mistakes I have made
even in the last six to seven years as a
leader at think media now as the CEO of
our company with about 20 W2 employees
and 10 contractors over the last six
years there's been times when I don't
feel like I have been a leader worth
following however my goal my prayer my
time the investment I've made the
investment in mentorship has been to try
to address those character gaps those
character issues to be on the path to
growth I think one thing that will be
helpful to the audience that is watching
or following you one thing that will be
helpful to the family that's coming
along with you one thing that will be
helpful to the team that eventually you
enroll and enlist on this journey is
that they just see that you're humble
and willing to keep growing that you're
honest about your weaknesses but you're
willing to keep growing none of us are
already there we all have flaws and
scars and issues but we need to be
committed to the process of becoming
leaders worth following and if you'll
commit to growth and development today
I'm convinced that that will lead to
becoming the person you need to be
tomorrow that will be
the person that will reach the goals
you've set on YouTube number four don't
just look good be good General
klausowitz said a couple hundred years
ago that vanity is content with
appearance alone and man this quote
could it be more relevant to us in a
modern YouTube world I think that too
many creators are content with vanity
what could that be it could be
appearance alone appearance could be
views some people buy views and I want
to encourage you if you've done it
there's nothing really you can do to
undo it but stop doing it it's not going
to help it can just kind of mess up the
algorithm they're not real people Bots
are not helpful but who cares about
appearance we don't want to just look
good we want to be good but maybe we're
not buying views the other thing we need
to know is that not all views are the
same sometimes content creators get
distracted thinking views are the only
metric for success but I don't really
want to see your views account I want to
see your bank account if you're trying
to build a real business what are the
economics what's the business model
behind the channel a lot of viral
Sensations are here today but they're
gone tomorrow vanity is content which is
looking good my view count looks good my
channel looks good my photos on
Instagram look good but that's just
appearance what's the substance
underneath the surface an interesting
thing I learned from our episode with
Renee Ritchie on a YouTube employee was
actually that a lot of shorts views are
less like views and more like
Impressions now I hope this doesn't
discourage you but if you've noticed
that new channels and smaller channels
can get a thousand or two thousand or
three thousand views on YouTube shorts
I'm not saying that they're not views
but what he was saying was the way
shorts work is they need to get
distributed a little bit in the shorts
feed essentially getting a view but it's
more like an impression if the video is
not actually consumed the cool thing is
that YouTube is being generous to
smaller channels and it is like giving
them bursts of reach to see how people
react if people consume it but this is
the key if you look at that and are like
oh sweet I got 3 000 views the question
is to ask what was the real impact there
this is why we teach a lot of people for
example to build an email list because
if somebody would actually go from
YouTube to trusting you to checking out
a free gift you have for them or a
fruity class or something then there's a
level of actual substance a level of
actual depth and it's not just wow I'm
getting so many views on my YouTube
shorts well does anybody want to go
deeper into your email list your patreon
your channel memberships the actual
substance of a thing and not just the
vanity of a thing the general said
vanity is content with appearance alone
and going a little bit harder on YouTube
shorts you know it's ultimately kind of
a trap now I'm all for them and we've
got a lot of views coming out but the
behind the scenes of the channel is not
just the public view count but it's also
the RPM that's the actual Revenue you
generate from views and the truth is
YouTube shorts are paying around two
four six the highest I've seen is nine
cents per a thousand monetizable views
on the flip side a lot of creators I'm
talking to are getting anywhere from a
dollar fifty at think media we're
getting around eight dollar RPMs and so
that's not the vanity metric that's the
real substance the real money behind the
scenes so think media our main channel
is I think hovers around 28 000 to up to
forty thousand dollars a month in
YouTube ad Revenue oh but you're not
getting zillions of views like this
other Creator sure but what's behind the
scenes falling into vanity is a trap
being content with appearance alone is a
trap but I think we can take this quote
from the general even deeper and really
think about what's behind the scenes of
not just our YouTube channel but our
business maybe our family our marriage
our personal lives even our mental
health our spiritual health because we
don't want to just be content with the
appearance alone we actually we don't
want to just look good we want to
actually be good I don't want to just
look happy I actually want to be happy
like behind all the YouTube videos we
post and all the social media posts is
the team that's running think media is
it healthy how is the team doing and
then behind the positive leadership
talks and the stuff I'm saying to the
team is the actual p l like it might be
we might be talking a big game but could
we be about to go out of business if our
profit is lower you know than our loss
and behind the business and the numbers
of the business is my marriage what's
the strength of my marriage behind my
Public Image is my private family life
and my relationship with myself and my
mental health and the conversation in my
own head and behind all of that is my
relationship with my Creator who knows
my thoughts and knows my motives and
knows everything about me and I know we
kind of took this to a crazy place but I
feel like it's so important and I want
to thank you for being a think media
podcast listener because of course we
want to build our public influence I
want to help you build your platform I
want to help you be more influential get
more followers and look better I want
you to look good and look happy but I'm
way more concerned that you would
actually be happy that you want to just
look good you would be good that you
wouldn't be content with vanity but that
you would have peace in your soul you'd
have joy like a river there would be an
unbreakable inner confidence that isn't
blown to and fro in the Wind of your
channels up your Channel's down and that
you would have Smart wisdom behind the
scenes of your YouTube channel so that
you could survive in any economy so that
you could ride the waves of higher and
lower cpms and RPMs because the business
you've built is set up intelligently
it's set up strategically you have
Diversified income streams so you don't
just look good and have those public
vanity metrics but you actually are good
and you have internal health the four
YouTube success secrets to help you gain
an unfair Advantage our strike when you
see the opportunity choose winnable
battles lead by example and don't just
look good be good now if you want more
help with creating a winning strategy
for crushing it on YouTube right now I
want to encourage you to check out our
free class at thinkmasterclass.com it's
available on demand and imagine having
the chance to sit with me looking over
my shoulder at the exact play-by-play
strategy I would do right now to get
views and ultimately create passive
income from YouTube Not Just vanity
metrics not just looking good but
actually being good you can stream that
instantly just click the link in the
show notes or go to thinkmasterclass.com
and also if you are finding this
battlefield for views you know military
strategy lessons we can apply to YouTube
series valuable we have a playlist it's
a multi-part series and we'll link that
up in the show notes and there's a
couple other great episodes in this
series and then also like rate and
review this podcast wherever you listen
to it or watch it and if you're on
YouTube leave me a comment with maybe
your favorite aha moment or any feedback
that you have let me leave you with an
ending inspirational quote from General
cloudzowitz there are times when the
utmost daring is the height of wisdom
dare to be great we'll talk soon